a new 6.5 billion year European maritime
in fisheries fund aims to get younger
people involved greener fishing and
maritime surveillance but with more than
half the budget allocated for subsidies
environmentalists say dance the culture
of overfishing and fleet over capacity
but the author of the report says
they're wrong nozomi one motorist ed
suki laura is exaggerated to come debe
to do nani mo 0 NT Valadez mata KO n'ya
nova co-producers nova control lamantia
yanma maximum yo hablo de razon see
sample modem use your key permit oppa
sure do continuous Hawaii on bank initio
impressive all our sauce Parliament's
Foreign Affairs Committee met on Monday
to discuss at the situation in Egypt
last Wednesday's coup that ousted
Egypt's first democratically elected
president following nationwide protests
has now seen over 50 supporters of
former president Mohamed Morsi killed in
bloody clashes with the army as violence
escalates what do any peace think it
would be a disaster not just for the
Egyptian people for the region for the
neighbors like Europe to have Egypt
drown in violence in military autocratic
rule cybercrime is big business figures
show it comes victims worldwide 290
billion euros but a profit for criminals
are staggering 750 billion euros the
internal market committee discussed a
cybersecurity on Tuesday I'm not
convinced that we need a directive these
are member state competences whether
it's criminal attacked or whether it's
more defense-related attacks and of
course we have seen now that Europe is
under attack the prism scandal shows
that very clearly that even countries
that we thought we could regard as our
friends are in fact attacking European
interest